allez l'actualité en france à présent
avec cette lanceuse d'alert américaine
frances organe qui est reçu aujourd'hui
à l'assemblée et au sénat environ un
ancien cadre de facebook elle avait
révélé le fonctionnement interne de la
société en accusant facebook de faire
passer le profit avant la sécurité de
ses utilisateurs
pour en savoir plus on va retrouver tout
de suite notre reporter david khalifa
devant le palais bourbon
bonjour david le parlement qui entend
aujourd'hui française au ghana quoi
peut-on s'attendre
attendre de cette audition précisément
et bien magali c'est d'abord avoir des
réponses après londres lisbonne berlin
et à bruxelles français saoudienne
poursuit sa tournée européenne
elle sera dans un premier temps
auditionné ce matin par les commissions
des lois et des affaires économiques à 9
heures ici même à l'assemblée nationale
puis au sénat cet après midi des séances
qui devrait durer entre 1h30 et 2h alors
de nombreuses questions vont être posées
à française à enghien dans les députés
comme sénateurs sont curieux de
connaître les coulisses de l'univers de
facebook etc à dérive avec un but bien
précis savoir si ce qui est mis en place
en france et en europe est suffisant
pour protéger les individus en ligne de
mire le règlement général sur la
protection des données ou à hergé
ou au futur la directive européenne
écoute
je souhaite qu'elle confirme certains
diagnostics l'assurance que facebook
fonctionne comme une mafia comme une
entreprise pas du tout scrupuleuse avec
ses utilisateurs savoir si il y à des
processus de validation des
vérifications sur les effets toxiques
sur les utilisateurs entendre quelqu'un
qui va dire explicitement ce qui se
passe c'est bien c'est un sujet qui nous
préoccupe c'est un travail parlementaire
prospectifs elle illustre ce que sont le
rôle et l'impact des lanceurs d'alert
sur l'opinion publique
un sujet qui préoccupe effectivement
puisque la commission de yale brawn
peavey examinera après l audition deux
propositions loi sur la protection des
lanceurs d'alerté sur le rôle du
défenseur des droits en matière de
signalements en alerte alors d'habiles
on a déjà eu certains éléments de
réponse concernant ces questions sur la
protection des individus au parlement
européen lundi
effectivement à bruxelles un français
saoudienne a salué le potentiel énorme
du projet européen de régulation des
géants du numérique elle s'est exprimée
devant les eurodéputés elle a accusé à
nouveau son ancien employeur de nuire
aux enfants attiser les divisions
affaiblir les démocraties et de faire
passer le profit avant la sécurité des
utilisateurs
la lanceuse d'alert estime que le
règlement sur les services numériques le
digital services act actuellement
examiné par le parlement européen
pourrait devenir une référence dans le
monde écoute et
je suis heureuse que l'union européenne
prenne cette question très au sérieux
le digital services act qui est
actuellement examiné par le parlement a
le potentiel pour devenir une référence
mondiale ça peut inspirer d'autres pays
dont le mien à prendre en charge de
nouvelles prérogatives afin de protéger
nos démocrates
voient là pour rappel le ds avait
interdire aux plateformes d'utiliser les
algorithmes pour promouvoir de fausses
informations et de discours dangereux
avec pour les plus importantes d'entre
elles une obligation de moyens pour
modérer elle est contenue française à
hogan souhaite que la loi soit apporté
son application ferme envers à facebook
et à tente tant bien que mal de redorer
son blason avec en détournant
l'attention que de nouveaux projets en
annonçant surtout un changement de nom
pour le groupe qui s'appelle désormais
mais tarde depuis plusieurs semaines
merci beaucoup david pour toutes ces
précisions david khalifa en direct du
palais bourbon ce matin